team kelly's ryan gallagher had to exit
the competition so the four-way
winner it was decided based on the votes
received
for these three remaining artists the
voices season 19
live shows kicked off on monday but they
were short one contestant
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah ryan gallagher the 31 year old
classically trained vocalist from adam
michigan
was one of the competitors in the
four-way knockout which took place last
week
but when carson daly announced the
winner at the top of monday's show
he revealed that ryan who was repping
team kelly clarkson in the face-off for
that last remaining spot in the top 17
had a bounce from the competition i
didn't drop out of the show
details are still to come i'll keep
posting
fans speculated that ryan's sudden
departure from the show was
family related since he had previously
shared that his mom had been
hospitalized
due to covet 19. it's been a hard
weekend that's for sure my mom just got
admitted
last night she has covered pretty bad
but on monday night ryan hit up
instagram story to let everyone know
that his fam
is doing just fine thank you everybody
for your concern for my family
however everybody's fine that's not the
cause of what happened tonight on
the voice well et has learned that
ryan's departure
is because he broke the voice's strict
covet 19 protocols
and therefore wasn't allowed to continue
in the competition to keep the coaches
crew and fellow competitors safe ryan
later shared this tuxedo selfie to a
story writing
2020 you are an interesting one
[Music]
but ryan's split from the show wasn't
the only buzz worthy moment of the night
this show is called the voice whenever
you ever
in your life heard a voice like that
blake shelton
almost broke the six foot social
distancing restrictions
after ian flanagan delivered a cover of
bob dylan's
make you feel my love how close can i
get and what a time
you're far enough cowboy for that you're
plenty right there but
don't go back to your chats
another highlight gwen stefani debuting
that
engagement ring bling from blake
somebody
that is humble kind
down to earth selfless talented
on the top of their game should i keep
going
i think i'm his biggest fan the season
19 blind auditions
battle rounds and knockouts were all
taped before the two went public with
their happy news in october which means
the live shows
are the first time the singer has been
rocking her epic sparkler
it's incredible to have a best friend
like that guy
but before the season kicked off gwen
told et how excited the coaches were to
be back
bringing music and joy to the fans at
home i think that being able to sit down
and watch a show that's so inspiring
will bring inspiration to people it will
definitely bring
joy music is uh is the heartbeat of of
human beings so
i feel really blessed to be here and be
part of that and to be
able to connect around america
on the tv
you